>> DID SOMEONE UPDATE THIS FOR
POLITICAL REASONS?
>> NO, OUR NORTH STAR HAS BEEN
LISTENING TO GUIDANCE OF HEALTH
AND MEDICAL EXPERTS AND TEAMS
AND THAT IS WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
THIS CASE.
>> Juan: THE WHITE HOUSE PLAYING
DEFENSE AFTER REPUBLICANING
CLAIM THE ANNOUNCEMENT ON MASK
WEARING WAS MEANT TO DISTRACT
FROM OTHER PROBLEMS FACING
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND THE CDC
DIRECTOR, SHE'S TAKING HEAT OVER
DRAMATIC TURN IN MESSAGING AFTER
PREVIOUSLY WARNING OF IMPENDING
DOOM A FEW WEEKS AGO.
FORMER TOP HEALTH OFFICIAL
TAKING ISSUE WITH COMMENTS LIKE
THAT.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A CRAZY WEEK,
JUST LAST WEEK THE KENTUCKY SAID
IF WE CONTINUE EVERYTHING,
MASKING, SOCIAL DISTANCING,
CASES WOULD GO UP.
WEDNESDAY NIGHT DR. ROCHELLE
WALENSKY WAS DOUBLING DOWN ON
MASKING.
DR. FAUCI SAID TO MASK INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE AND COMPLETE
TURNAROUND YESTERDAY AFTERNOON.
IT HAS BEEN A MESS OF MESSAGING.
>> Juan: NOT EVERYONE IS ONBOARD
WITH THE NEW MASK RULES, MANY
BLUE STATES ARE STILL EVALUATING
THEIR MANDATES AND SOME IN THE
MEDIA, WELL, THEY SAY IT WILL
TAKE A WHILE FOR AMERICANS TO
ADAPT.
>> I FEEL LIKE I'M GOING TO HAVE
TO REWIRE MYSELF SO WHEN I SEE
SOMEBODY OUT IN THE WORLD NOT
WEARING A MASK, I DON'T
INSTANTLY THINK, YOU ARE A
THREAT OR YOU ARE SELFISH OR YOU
ARE A COVID DENIER AND HAVEN'T
BEEN VACCINATED.
WE'LL HAVE TO REWIRE THE WAY WE
LOOK AT EACH OTHER.
>> Juan: WILL CAIN, LET ME START
WITH YOU.
I THINK IT HAS BEEN GOOD NEWS
COMING FROM THE CDC, WE SAY
RACHEL SAYING SHE WILL HAVE TO
REWIRE HER THINKING, WHAT DOES
WILL CAIN SAY?
>> I CAN'T FOLLOW YOU ON THAT
THIS IS GOOD NEWS.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS SCIENCE AND
CDC AND SCIENCE IN QUOTATION
MARKS.
THIS IS SOMETHING EVERYDAY
AMERICANS HAVE KNOWN FOR MONTHS,
YOU CAN WALK AROUND OUTSIDE AND
EVEN INSIDE IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED WITHOUT A MASK.
THE WHITE HOUSE AND CDC HAVE
MADE THESE REASONS FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
WE CAN DEBATE THE REASONS MAY
BE, I FIND IT FASCINATING WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT RACHEL MAD DOW,
THIS IS ABOUT SOMETHING OTHER
THAN SCIENCE.
RACHEL FOUND CHEAP UNEARNED
VIRTUE WEARING A MASK WHEN
SOMEONE ELSE DID NOT.  THEY SAW
THEMSELVES AS BELIEVERSS IN
SCIENCE.
NOW THEY HAVE LOST THEIR
IDENTITY, THEY HAVE BEEN LEFT
NAKED, NOT IN TERMS OF FACE, NOT
HAVING IDENTITY ANYMORE.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO GIVE
VIRTUE OVER YOU ANYONE.
NEVER ABOUT SCIENCE FOR YOU.
>> Juan: JESSE, WILL THINKS IT
IS POLITICS AND VIRTUE
SIGNALLING.
I NOTICE 70% OF AMERICANS THINK
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS DEPUTY
A GREAT JOB ON HANDLING THE
PANDEMIC, SO DID HE JUST PASS
THE BIGGEST TEST OF HIS
PRESIDENCY?
>> Jesse: I'M TRYING TO COME TO
TERMS WITH WILL CAIN'S RACHEL
NAKED ANALOGY.
GIVE ME A MINUTE.
REMEMBER SLICK WILLIE, HE WAS
WAGGING THE DOG, HE WAS LOBBING
CRUISE MISSILES INTO THE MIDEAST
DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE
LEWINSKI SCANDAL.
THIS IS PR 101.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS, THAT
MOUMENT THIS MASK ANNOUNCEMENT
WAS NOT ON THE BIDEN SCHEDULE
AND HE WAS LATE FOR THE
ANNOUNCEMENT.
HE HAS THE LIGHTEST SCHEDULE
SINCE EISENHOWER.
WHEN THEY ADD TO HIS SCHEDULE,
IT'S A REALLY BIG DEAL AND HE
WAS LATE.
THAT IS BECAUSE THEY WERE
SCRAMBLING TO GET THIS OUT HERE.
HE DOESN'T WATCH CABLE NEWS, THE
PRESIDENT.
HE ONLY READS THE NEWSPAPER.
THE OTHER MORNING, THE
NEWSPAPERS, "WASHINGTON POST,"
BIG STORIES ABOUT HOW INFLATION,
LABOR SHORTAGE AND GAS PRICES
WERE CONVERGING TO UPSET HIS
INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL AND UPSET
THE RECOVERY.
SO THEY PLAYED THIS CARD AND
TRUMP DID IT ALL THE TIME, SO
CAN YOU BLAME HIM?
HE WAS A LOT BETTER AT IT, HE
DID IT WITH HIS FINGERS OR HIS
MOUTH AND SENT THE PRESS
SCRAMBLING.
WHEN BIDEN DOES IT, NOT TOO GOOD
AT IT, IT IS BLATANT WHEN HE
DOES IT.
I DID GET EXCITED IN THE
BEGINNING WHEN THEY MADE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT, I THOUGHT, GREAT,
NO MASK.
I REALIZED IT WAS JUST FEDERAL
GUIDANCE.
THEY ARE SAYING I CANNOT WEAR A
MASK INSIDE A FEDERAL BUILDING.
WHEN AM I EVER IN A FEDERAL
BUILDING, JUAN, WHEN I FW TO THE
POST OFFICE?
I NEVER GO TO THE POST OFFICE.
IN NEW YORK, DE BLASIO AND
ANDREW CUOMO STILL MAKE ME WEAR
A MASK, IT IS STATUS QUO, RED
STATE NO MASK MANDATE.
BLUE STATE, YOU STILL HAVE IT.
UNLESS YOU ARE IN A POST OFFICE,
DOESN'T DO MUCH FOR ME.
>> Juan: HMM.
KENNEDY, IN FACT, PICKING UP ON
JESSE'S THOUGHT THERE, PELOSIS
YOU HAVE TO WEAR A MASK ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR.
AND I THINK PART OF HER
RATIONALE IS LIKE THE NEW YORK
YANKEES JUST HAD AN OUTBREAK AND
THEY HAVE ALL BEEN VACCINATED.
LIKE EIGHT MEMBERS OF THE
TRAVELING, I BELIEVE A PLAYER
EVEN, STILL GOT THE VIRUS.
HOW DO YOU MAKE SENSE OF THIS?
>> AS AN EPIDEMIOIOLOGIST, JUAN,
I AM GLAD YOU ASKED ME.
WITH NANCY PELOSI, IT IS REALLY
ABOUT CONTROL.
SHOW WON'T LISTEN TO SCIENCE.
SHE HAS MANY DOCTORS IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES, WHO
COULD EXPLAIN TO HER THAT
NATURAL IMMUNITY FROM PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HAD THE VIRUS, PLUS PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN VACCINATED AND
RECEIVED IMMUNITY THAT WAY, THAT
IS ENOUGH PEOPLE, IF THEY CHOOSE
NOT TO WEAR MASKS, THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WEAR MASKS.
THIS IS THE GOVERNMENT FIGHTING
WITH ITSELF.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
15-DEGREE SHIFT WITH SOME
POSITIVE NUMBERS ABOUT
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS
BEING DOWN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A 180-DEGREE
TURN IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
IN A NUMBER OF WEEKS.
JEN PSAKI SAYS NORTHSTAR IS THE
MEDICAL EXPERTS AND THEY FOLLOW
THE MEDICAL EXPERTS.
THE MEDICAL EXPERTS ARE
FOLLOWING THE TEACHER'S UNION,
SO SCIENCE IS REALLY THE LAST
ENTITY IN LINE HERE THAT IS
INFORMING SOME OF THE DECISIONS.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY WAGGED THE DOG,
BUT AT LEAST THE DOG IS BEING
WAGGED IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION,
IN THE DIRECTION OF FREEDOM AND
I WILL TAKE THAT.
>> Juan: THAT'S A GOOD POINT,
MARTHA, I THINK LOTS OF PEOPLE
ON THE RIGHT, IN FACT, WANTED
THE CDC AND JOE BIDEN TO SAY,
YOU DON'T NEED TO WEAR THE MASK
IF YOU'VE BEEN VACCINATED.
HERE WE ARE AND PEOPLE ARE
CRITICIZING THEM FOR SAYING
DON'T WEAR THE MASK.
IS THIS JUST PARTY AND POLITICS?
>> A LOT OF PARTISAN POLITICS,
WHITE HOUSE OPPORTUNISM IN TERMS
OF TIMING.
IT'S BEEN A LOUSY WEEK FOR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, A LOT OF
PLACES LIFTED MASK MANDATES A
LONG TIME AGO.
AS JESSE POINTS OUT IN NEW YORK,
THEY WILL HANG ON TO THEIR MASKS
FOR A WHILE.
THE THING I WANT TO MAKE A POINT
ABOUT, HERD IMMUNITY, IT WAS A
DIRTY WORD, NOT ALLOWED TO TALK
ABOUT HERD IMMUNITY.  THEY WERE
ABLE TO MAKE THIS DECISION FROM
THE CDC IS THAT WE HAVE 36% OF
THE COUNTRY VACCINATED AND
KENNEDY WAS TOUCHING ON THIS
POINT.
NOT TOO LONG AGO, DR. FAUCI SAID
GET TO 70 OR 80%, HE BASIC HE
PUSHED BACK.
MARTY MCCARY, ON FOX SAID WE
WERE GETTING CLOSE TO HERD
IMMUNITY, PROBABLY HAPPEN IN THE
END OF APRIL.
YOU HAVE A THIRD OF THE COUNTRY
FULLY VACCINATED AND YOU STARTED
TO SEE CASE NUMBERS DROPPING AND
DEATH NUMBERS DROPPING.
THE REASON FOR THAT, THERE ARE
FEWER AND FEWER PLACES FOR THE
VIRUS TO GO, BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAD IT WHO DIDN'T KNOW
THEY HAD IT OR HAVE T-CELL
IMMUNITY.
ALL OF WHAT HE HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR QUITE SOMETIME THAT
WERE MOCKED BY DR. FAUCI HAVE
GIVEN THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET TO THE POINT THEY GOT TO
YESTERDAY AND THEY DID IT AT A
MOMENT THEY NEEDED IT.
THAT IS THE FACT, IT IS
DIFFICULT TO SEE ANY OTHER WAY.
>> Juan: WELL, I HOPE YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE NOW WITHOUT THE
MASK, MARTHA.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Juan: WILL YOU HAVE TO CHANGE
LIKE RACHEL MADDOW?
>> I HAD TO USE THE DISPOSABLE
ONE ALL THE TIME.
NO PROBLEM DROPPING THE MASK, I
WILL BE THRILLED TO DROP THE
MASK.
RACHEL CAN KEEP HER MASK IF SHE
WANTS TO FOR AS LONG AS SHE
LIKES.
IT IS REALLY SAD SHE LOOKED AT
PEOPLE AS A THREAT, AS AN
ANTI-VA XXER, SOMEBODY WITH EVIL
INTENTION BECAUSE THEY WERE
OUTSIDE AND WALKING IN THE AREA
SHE WAS WALKING.
GUESS HOW MANY TRACEABLE CASES
THERE ARE OF COVID TRANSMISSION
OUTSIDE?
NEXT TO NONE.
>> RIGHT NOW, MARTHA.
RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT WHOLE IDEA WAS A FAL SEE
TO BEGIN WITH AND WE NOW KNOW